now that I've seen this a number of
times you've said there would it be no
movie without Stephanie as you call her
Lady Gaga and you're right and obviously
when you two met there was an instant
connection there and that connection
survives to this day did you ever even
talk to anyone else any actors any
singers about doing this role or was it
kind of like you met her and then
conversation over when Clint Eastwood
first approached me about talking about
potentially doing a movie Beyonce was
attached to it and then and then that
that that was that was the sort of the
the the journey and then I thought about
one other person but then I sort of just
put it away and I thought maybe I was
never gonna make it and then and then I
had and I saw her and we talked about
this I was at this cancer benefit that
Sean Sean Parker's house with my mother
because I was starting a foundation
because my father had passed away from
cancer and the last performance was Lady
Gaga singing a cover of Libyan rose and
it just completely floored me and I was
like in this sort of state of euphoria
driving home and I and that night I woke
up the next day and I called her agent
ice is there any way that she would meet
with me because you know I think that
she might be perfect for this movie and
and that and then she was kind of to
meet with me and then that's that's how
it started and then once once I actually
met her cuz I I didn't really know her I
didn't even really know what she looked
like and but really you know I didn't
know what her eyes looked at any that
yeah and and then it was just right away
I thought oh my gosh she's first of all
she's a incredible human being so
present and kind and warm and
charismatic and and then and then we
just she seemed to really jive with this
story that I wanted to tell and then it
started and then that was it and then I
was completely had blinders on and there
was no movie without her salmon he
brought you back after you thought you
had wrapped you did what a head wept I
mean it wasn't even a matter of thinking
and I had wrapped so how did that
conversation I had a text I got it it
came to me via text from Bradley we
texted a lot off and on through I kind
of came and went
obviously as I did in the show and I got
a text after I trapped and Bradley said
what do you think about this and I
thought holy [ __ ] I like that idea a lot
and when you're talking about it
it was it was the same with Stephanie in
the end and initially it was to be dice
I believe for dad that was gonna come
and talk to her you know and comfort her
and Bradley for whatever reason decided
it needed to be Bobby and I'm gonna be
forever beholden to him and forever
grateful that he made that decision
because it was one of my favorite
moments for me and you know in this
journey that great moment were Bradley's
character gets out of the truck has that
wonderful line about how he idolized you
and then there's that great moment where
we see you backing up and and it's
filled with emotion but it was also a
bit of legit of a logistical nightmare
with your getting the camera operators
to sit in the right way right well I
mean everything's a logistical nightmare
in this movie because of budget
constraints and time but that's sort of
we were just talking about you know how
to necessity comes a opportunity and
ideas and creativity and you know the
thing that Maddie and I always talked
about ever even from the beginning and
then every day is how can we get the
composition we want while also allowing
the actors to feel completely free and
we often did long takes where and and so
what we did was I mean we had two
cameras in the back of the truck and we
talked about I'm gonna I'm gonna leave
and then man I think Maddie you were a
so you went down and then Chris got the
got Sam so Chris was able to get sick
Scott Scott's got Sam and and because I
and so that and so we just created an
environment so that Sam could be as free
as possible while at the same time
getting the shot that we wanted in a
general sense Matthew how did you go
about achieving the sense of intimacy
that really comes across in the film
well I just want to say one thing about
that moment is I was on Bradley when he
got out of the car and Scott our a
camera operator
on sand and I saw I didn't see Sam's
performance so I went down to the house
that we shot at that was Jack vanes
house went to the video playback and I
watched it and when I saw that second
take I ran over to Scott and I said why
the [ __ ] didn't you tell me that that
happened you didn't say anything and I
was like it's probably one of the most
magical things I've ever seen
like the the greatest reaction I think
I've ever seen as a cameraman as long as
I've been there but I mean intimacy is
it's it's equal parts performance and
proximity that's it so it's like we
spend every the beginning of every scene
Bradley and I would spend every moment
trying to figure out where the right
place to put the camera was not how many
shots we needed but where the camera
needed to be and if we felt like we
needed another thing we'd get another
thing and it was a liberating way to
work because there was a singular vision
Aaron for you what was the story you
were trying to tell through wardrobe
because that's always fascinating to
hear the costume designers talk about
how clothes evolved throughout the arc
of a story sure you know I think the
thing that was most unique about this
movie was that I had to listen to music
in order to figure out what to put our
actors in you know and that changed
completely I know if you remember
Bradley but we started off and I wanted
to do leather pants yeah until we found
Jackson Maine but it yeah I think you
know I think it was it was hearing the
music listening to the music and finding
the character finding the in to the
character that way Jay one of the things
that Bradley told me about some of the
musical scenes is that he wanted it to
have a documentary look and feel to it
and you definitely reminded of the Last
Waltz another great film
documentaries how if at all did that
impact your work as the editor did that
did that affect the choices that you
made a Bradley shot the concerts with
the point of view that you're always on
stage with the performer looking out at
the at the audience you so you you never
have a camera that's photographing from
the audience's point of view so once
once that decision is made and that that
I sort of concede is established it
meant that you were gonna the cutting
was almost easy because instead of
having 18 cameras like you'd think on a
concert film you'd to and so the the the
intent was always to keep the shots as
long as they play and and stay with the
performer and and not and getting to
kind of get out of the way of of the
performance so that you just felt it
what's the one thing when you watch this
movie where you look at your own work in
it and you think I cannot believe we
pulled that off
I think the first moment we get to see
Ali not on stage or not you know sort of
plain Ali is though is that was a was
the most fun most hard most challenging
and great moment for a lot of us when
she's watching him do the solar moment
in the with the guitar and exactly and
they're about to go out and write it was
sort of establishing who is Ali and who
what kind of girl is she and where does
she come from and what is she interested
in how strong does she feel about
herself and how does she feel in the
world how does she move in the world and
I know that was a really cool moment for
us to figure out and I know I mean Karen
and I spent like weeks while there are
like daughter's were playing over on the
side of each other's houses just looking
at tons of pictures of musicians and old
musicians and ex musicians and just like
trying to figure out who this girl was
how about the rest of you
for me it's really I think one of the
first conversation I ever had with
Bradley like I said we met quite cold
you know we just like I just get to LA
and I'm like hi and we and then we just
hit it off it was really beautiful but I
think the biggest thing was just we
didn't start getting very specific it
was more about how it was gonna feel and
I think for me it was a lot of things I
didn't do so I thought it was very
important for the authenticity of those
concerts I actually was I had to a
manager in my life for a while a long
time ago and did a lot of backstage you
know just being a person there on the
backstage and I thought it was very
important for that to be extremely
authentic so often we did we went to
places that we went to Coachella we went
to stagecoach we went to Glastonbury we
went to venues around Los Angeles where
they're really different really
beautiful and we used them for what they
were which and we found people to help
in my departments to create that we
actually had a tour manager who worked
with us who's in the film and he's you
know the crew yeah yeah Jack Jack means
[Music]
everybody they're all they're all
they're all work in the industry so we
were very connected to the industry
which I think for me was like important
and and I think it shows in the film and
definitely shows what the most
miraculous aspect of it for you I mean
the fact that we all did it
quite honestly yeah and that all these
people entrusted themselves to me is
very I don't know if I'll ever get over
that but but specifically every day was
hard every day was hard and that and I
wouldn't have it any other way and I
think that's why I made us all have to
dig it deeper who's definitely deeper
than I've ever dug before and I thought
I dug very deep before but not like this
but but there's something about jumping
onto a set that you have there no
control over and you know I you know
she's the real deal and the movie had to
be as authentic as she is and certainly
the concert scenes and and Karen's right
I mean she was dogmatic from day one and
we sir
we looked at other options and she was
stalwart and saying no you know no in a
great way no and thank God you know and
so it's like okay we got to jump on real
stages and Maddie and I flew to London
with Steve Maura the sound guy just
three of us and we jumped on glad the
stage a glass of Barry and we had four
minutes and that was probably the most
terrifying and exhilarating four minutes
most of all because when we got there we
realized that the band had just played
there were nine people on the stage so
there were nine microphones and that
would have been like a labyrinth for the
camera operator so we're like throwing
that's the mics down and they're yelling
at us he only have four minutes and then
we just jumped on in front of 80,000
people and sang two songs and got out of
there and and it was really crazy and
and we did the say the opening the movie
is stagecoach we had eight minutes and
that one we we had really talked about
and the idea of stunted that remember
the shot with it in between the two
guitars and trying to get trying to get
our compositions within eight minutes
was so wonderful to watch the crew all
of us work together as a unit that's the
thing I love so much is that you know we
all have equal parts in this movie it's
like I look it's and and also the people
that aren't here Mike cest and Mike
Sexton and Shelley Ziegler and so many
people like it really was a unit a unit
made this movie that's why this this art
form is so wonderful it's about
community and collaboration and
everybody is a voice and that's that's
the thing I just want to keep doing keep
doing and who was the nice musical
artists who yielded four minutes of his
set to you Chris go stop it's just too
perfect
guys congratulations on the movie I'm so
happy you all were here